Why did you actually get your shoes. But. Yeah that's a good question and many different areas. I could have picked.
But I had a very good professor. Who. Total how actually. Plans to get sick.
Like humans like kind of man's plants also get a lot of disease bacterial diseases viral diseases.
Fungal diseases made out of diseases
and they get sick then we have no food so that was really in a simplified a way that was the reason
and I found it very interesting also the science of plant pathology which is diseases of plants. Yeah.
You went from you say that you. You went to the shelter. What did you do and so yeah. So I studied in.
My undergraduate degree in Europe. Yes and I go to scholarship went to the United States.
That's what I really wanted to do and so I studied there and I had. I did my master's degree and my Ph D.
Degree in America and I had also After my Ph D. I had a job as a scientist in in the U.S. In Cornell University and.
So after that I was recruited by an international agricultural research center based in Colombia.
So I had never been in Colombia before. They approached me to consider a job there.
So I was employed by the organization as a senior scientist and then I moved in Colombia. Yeah.
What are you doing in Colombia so I was. A senior scientist in charge of. Diseases so for. Forage plants.
And it's a very enjoyable. Sitting job. Because everything we did was to sort of problem for society.
Particularly for developing countries. It's a great phase for me and I get to learn a new language the Spanish.
The people are nice and.
The country is beautiful and I made my husband say it also he was at the same time
when I was recruited from United States the same company acquitted him also from the Netherlands from his country
and we made. One day apart. We arrived late and one day apart physically.
Saw him and then our daughter was also born there in Colombia. So.
Both of us also grew our scientists this was in the organization also so it is it is very good
and we we I felt we made a lot of difference for people so we were working for basically develop the developing world
in South America in Asia in Africa just based in Colombia.
So it was a very good time and you also educated a lot of Chinese students. Yes So you became a friend of China.
Yes I did so I think one of the exciting things is that. In that organization. You are a scientist.
For any developing countries that needs your skills and technology.
So you are not particularly working for just one country will be as are so many different students graduate students
came to work. With me so was many Chinese.
So the Chinese were partially funded by their government so they came to do research in my love what I told him says
they are really hardworking people
and I spend a considerable amount of time also training them so that was my one of the success so nice
and I had Colombian students I had but I was Elian so I had many different countries. So so so.
The Chinese It wasn't unnoticed that you educated emotional people you got a call from the Chinese.
Why did you decide to go to Africa. Yeah. So that's so that does a turning point for me.
So all those years I was in Colombia for fifteen years. So I agree was a scientist was in the organization.
I was promoted also in the organization. So it was for my career.
It was great but at the back of my mind I was also thinking
and I'm really contemplating also what is actually my impact for Africa coming from a from a privileged knowing how
people live separately to make in this meat so I I was only also with that Colombia needs me more than Africa
and needed me but I think the turning point came in September two thousand
and six as Chinese gave me their highest I worked with the Corps
and the French friendship I worked for their own I had played in their. And cultural research development.
And impact basically said was a graduate student so I three
and who have had become very successful scientists is back in China.
So at ceremonies it was a big ceremony here and on the stage
when it was announced at that time for me to have been to have made this this contribution to China. So it was.
It doesn't it's a proud moment for me to almost I was embarrassed.
You know I was from a poor country and I was getting Amidala going to weigh down from the Premier.
China after all the impact made in China and I was questioning with that on the stage.
There's actually China need me more than Africa. So that was the stage actually on the stage right there.
I decided OK I'm going back to Africa so. You became finally in Africa director of instict Institute. One image.
Issue to deal. Yeah. So when I came back to Africa I I was not immediately the head of this institute. So I.
I was recruited by an as an international organization based here in Nairobi to be established agriculture about
technology center for Africa. Funded by the Canadian government.
To the tough job a tough task
but it gave me a push to need to do something from scratch for Africa so I did that for five
and a half years to establish this center became a very successful Center has done a lot of money trend a set up the
program. And so on. So when I was approached by another organization.
If I could take the position of the vice president for programs.
So I accepted that but it does not it was her children ization So I. I was not.
I wanted to go back into them said children is a shame.
So this then this opportunity came to his superior International Center of insect physiology and ecology.
So I accepted that and so he did a perfect place for me was perfect programs what Africa.
So why insects so people often ask me why was a whole lot of Ghana zation for just insects
and why insects that's what he's Alaska. But yeah this is a unique organization.
I think as far as I know the only organization that deals hundred percent on insects.
Because insects are extremely important in our lives they are by far the most diverse and the most.
Abundant animals on earth they playing a very a sort of sea in our lives they if you take beasts.
Zany play a critical role in pollinating articles.
So if we have to disappear tomorrow our food source would be in big big trouble so the they pulling it out of court
crops like these insects also play a critical role as food source. Food for humans and feed for animals.
So about two billion people in Africa or Latin America is. Consume insect source of protein.
As I believe this is also actually a source that has to be mainstreamed citing the globe.
As a good source of high quality protein. Is also beasts. Give us also a lot of things. Food feed. I mean insects woks.
Range of things. Insects also they they have also acknowledged.
Also there are insects that controller's that harmful insects also insects play a role. Also in degrading waste.
Plant waste animal waste and so on.
So in fact if we don't have insects our Oleg would be a lot of critic I mean really mess. With a lot of garbage.
A lot of waste that we put which is not being degraded by. By some microbes and insects.
But unfortunately we're also that insects also are harmful to also to Humans are animals to crops.
They transmit a lot of disease small things like most Skittles killed more people than Every day is and.
You know global conflicts. Put together as well.
It hurts me to think like it was all to take knowledge is we have humans going mankind going to the moon
or going to space and so on. We are unable to defeat a tiny mosquito to have to kill every eighty seconds in Africa.
Children die from from malaria. Or from. Also a lot of. Transmitted Diseases.
And yellow fever
and a lot of the diseases scams that are transmitted through insects the same for animal diseases so so a wide range of
for animal disease is transmitted through insects.
So so climate change climate change is an issue that is Sun Freeport.
For example say is the one to the bank just came out if we don't do deal with climate change by twenty thirty one
hundred million more people who are going to over thirty.
So I think I believe personally that I think one of the biggest impacts of climate change is going to be inside sources.
So instead sort of going through as the only gets warmer insects are going to shift also to you a woman places so a lot
of African problems are going to be also a problem somewhere else as a guess what.
So if we have to do to make the planet livable for us in the many years ahead.
If we have to manage our food security needs security.
If we have to develop the the climate we have to deal so his insects one of the the benefits
and the harmful part of the of what insects.
Will there are people aware somehow of this wide variety of properties that. No unfortunately not.
I think we have to make people aware of of that I think we have to teach it.
You would you mind repeating my question sort of because I want you. Yes or no. Yeah.
So if you think people are aware somehow. Device for right you property.
Yeah no I think people are not aware of of all this variety of issues associated with insects.
So for example if you take beasts. Almost everybody knows that the honey comes from beasts.
But a lot of people don't know that bees are critical.
And so for food security is a they pollinate crops results beasts
and you don't have enough in some of the plants they require pollination by microbes by AS So you know people don't
know a lot of a lot about about this
and I think we have to teach it in school in elementary school in high school in universities
and I think in the general public.
Also to be aware of what insects do for a for people on the other properties you think of very beneficial for insects
pharmaceutical properties. If you will from yeah yeah. Insects play also as a.
For example there are insecticides are uniquely found antibiotics insecticides uniquely produce that have antibiotics
for example should we do it again. Yeah. Yeah. OK mention some other.
Well quite unique properties that we are not very aware. Yeah. Insects have a number of as a uses as well.
For example antibiotics for people for any mouse.
I don't think we have investigated enough the unique kind about except exist in insects.
There are also other things for example this insect called Soldier fly that are very good in in processing a lot of
waste and converting them into fertilizer.
So yeah there's a wide variety of use that we can make out of the out of insects and some of the airplane.
Helicopter design come source of fuel from insect insect architecture that. What do you make use of your interest you.
Yeah I think the uniqueness for me this is one he is focused on really solving.
Agricultural and health constraints in Africa.
But what we produce is not just unique for Africa it can be used globally.
Eighty's also we also focus on very environmentally friendly and sustainable technologies and products.
We have for example.
Over the years generated about besides besides that come naturally for a woman naturally for existing fungus.
And and we manage. Insects beneficial not beneficial harmful insects.
So this products now are commercial is that together with in partnership with the private sector.
And so it's registered now that registered didn't many countries in Africa.
And currently that have been grades are built so. In the European Union.
So what we produce very environmentally friendly
and not contaminating the environment not harming as a beneficial insects.
So it's not only just useful for Africa but this can be used anywhere else as well in Europe in North America.
So we are unique in states that we we focus on technology and products that are environmentally friendly
and that also sustainable for a long time or so and that gives And I actually believe very much so.
I'm bored and this is your institute for Africa. Maybe you despair.
I think is very very important I think I often ask my staff that if we cease to exist tomorrow would be people lined up
asking for. But the opening offer and the answer is constantly Yes.
Because we we are making a major impact all across Africa
and we are focused on major constraints constants that are really. Impediment for agricultural in Hull's. Issues so.
Very important a limitation for the whole of the continent and and globally as well. Why is it in Africa.
Why is it in Africa. Good question. Superiors in Africa because it was founded by Africa.
It was a founded forty five you say go in one thousand seventy by a very renowned in the morning just insect scientist.
Professor A Kenyan professor. So it was founded does as an international standard a small center was in a university.
And it expanded it expanded the and so today we have multiple nationalities of scientists and technical staff
and reaching out across Africa and making it back
and what I like about the organization is also that research yeah we do cutting edge research we do.
We make a major Brooks's brick suppose we publish in high quality Jordan and internationally
but all that work is also with him to translate it to impact is nothing we do which is not is a short term
or medium term or long term.
It's not translated to impact and production reach the end user which is the farmers and the beneficiaries in Africa
and beyond. And so. So this is really truly. Making science to work for the for the for people for society.
When you describe how important effect future. Yeah excellent very good question.
Yeah I think insects are really important for our lives. So I think bees.
Europe and North America already knows now because a bee population is going declining already knows that.
This is a problem unless we do this unless we take care of the hulls of the beasts.
So that when I think it was results say that if this if they don't exist today tomorrow we are in trouble. So.
That that has to go on for the future. I think for the future.
Also that if we have to diversify our foods foods source.
Feed source and quality of protein
and thing we have to man is three more so these are insects are as food so that is that out of via the more than two
thousand species of insects are consumed to global. About seven of them in Africa.
So people consume them go to the forests they collect them seasonally.
Often it is women and children who are tasked given these tasks to go to the forests and collect the insects but.
So sometimes when you collect also that you are going to there is a tendency of the to over harvest
and then you can cause some of this at all in balancing the the atmosphere there you can leave liam so.
And he simply has the technology. The capability to masquerade. A lot of this is species of insects.
But I think we have to change the perception of people.
Globally is that the that the insects I mean consuming snakes is not something out of the old ordinary two billion
people have successfully been trying to deny you consuming them. If we have to do mainstream and so.
So the conversion rate also a feed. And insect protein is a lot more efficient in sects.
So with a very limited amount of feed substrate to insects you can get high quality protein compared to the same
quality protein in beef in cattle. So for climate change. Also mitigation for. And so on so I think it's a sad move.
More compatible I think more sustainable.
One of your research actually published an article about locust you could better locust food. Yeah.
Can you explain what was what. Yeah. So we we have been working going now.
All the various insects also the protein
and nutritional profile of these insects also a number of insects that are being consumed traditionally So we found
that a lot of this insects actually have a higher or equivalent content of nutrition
and protein to be equivalent to fish and you beef is that is a good finding locusts.
So we published recently about two months ago.
Very exciting finding so locusts are really big pests they go and they can name a storm
and they can completely wipe your crops in an overnight they consume are a lot of greenery crops or any vegetation.
But but people also consume them traditionally And so in many parts of Africa and elsewhere so
but what we found is that not because they love what I thought they say things that are feed on seedlings they they
they they convert the with seedlings may have very minute amount of steroids.
This had chemicals that are very useful to to our health release cholesterol and they do a lot.
They have a lot of benefits to our health.
And so they look us as a consumer and then they we don't know the mechanisms there yet.
They have the in capacity to convert this. Steroids twenty to forty.
And so if you have a diet low cost the business right.
All across in your life incorporated into your diet that the chance of you having a store owner as that hurt.
Problem is much much lower.
So this is a amazing finding it so I think it's more
and more of who we are in the day the beneficial effect of Hull's beneficial effect of insects. As food.
I think the perception of people or so. We change and on incorporating it into the apply.
So if you inject research you do for the future of Africa.
I think if we have effective effectively understanding we are constantly understanding the insects as their physiology
is a recall of disease where they are mechanism how they transmitted diseases like that there are fascinating questions
for critters.
If we understand that our better if we know then we identified in several cycles sin their life cycle several spots
where the weak spots where we can manage. So I think we have to eradicate malaria. So why can't we.
With all this technology not just us but the global. Scientific community.
Why can't we eradicate dengue a way country eradicate says they fly south that causing a lot of problem was in humans
in the nineteen months on was so so I think if we tackle all this. I think the future of Africa will be bright.
It will be less nice problem to deal with.
So a lot of the problems you find in Africa there are that actually manageable we can manage them. We can tackle them.
So it's not this not. Yeah we. We regularly make bricks or as we recently that the younger group of scientists is.
Sippin my organization. They they've discovered that certain tools certain population of the most transmit malaria.
About a very small portion of them. We don't know why they they harbor. Bacteria in their body so that. These.
These bacteria as they are the Unable to transmit the malaria parasite. That is a major major discovery.
So what we have well what we are doing is that why. Why do what does.
What do these bacteria do to this insect is making them resistant.
And incapable of transmitting the the malaria transmitting the the malaria parasite.
And why only certain population a certain percentage of them are in the musky to have it.
So if we know that and if we are able to to transmit this bacteria to a wider range of the population.
It is possible to significantly reduces their malaria to that transmission.
So there's a lot of things we can do and we. And I make to make a difference in Africa and it's.
People I talk to say you would examine. That. Have been hairy men hairy and very impatient. Yeah because I think and I.
If you talk to my staff also they will tell you the same thing. I mean I am where I'm pushing going to Santa Lee.
I mean patient that is because I think we have to.
Live our lives with a sense of urgency because every day we leave that to morrow we have an hour.
Where are about to finish today tomorrow. We have one day less than the life of a lifetime.
So which means that we are not getting younger.
So we have to rush to make sure that we have actually make a difference in people's lives that we have lived also our
lives with a purpose. So I think we shouldn't do. I don't feel that I have to live for myself.
No I shouldn't live for myself I should feel a sense of responsibility for my as a fellow human beings that is so so
that's why I'm in a hurry.
I'm really no hurry to go I want to do I want to do law is something I want to make a difference for people.
I went to solve problems.
For poor people who are not able to solve it seems obvious and I think we are fortunate as a scientist.
I'm fortunate that I'm given this priceless knowledge and education.
So I have to use it to know the use it to publish a paper with only to really to use to serve the people's problems
and Chinese do for Africa. All science can do a lot of things will Africa and for the rest of the world.
I think we should do we should be able to find solutions for all our for our we should be finding vaccine for malaria.
We should be finding vaccine for a child. Who should be defending cancer. So that's one possible.
I think is so is science can do a lot of different things to for people and for the planet. What can.
Africa doofus write. Africa can do. Oh a lot of things for science.
I think that's an excellent question that no one has ever asked
and I think governments have to value this Heins technology is a really important for the continent development for the
people so they have to value that.
They have to invest a significant proportion of their of their resources to science and technology.
And to as an area it's because I think the difference between my country
and your country which is my husband's country is really not the difference in our color. It's not the difference in.
In the location where Riyad it's a difference of capability and education.
So that and investment and a capability capacity of people to you know of it.
Capacity of people to abse or with new technologies. And to invent a lot of different things.
If we don't do that if Africa doesn't desire never going to solve a lot of our problems.
So how is it that their misery lands which has a miserable Whizzer. And can produce a lot of food food.
Not only for these people but I think can produce a lot and we have this beautiful weather.
Beautiful sunshine and a lot of resources water and everything else and we're not feeding ourselves.
So it is again a capability I think if you will for me.
You know and knowledge and and technology and I think Africa has to do that to you. To enhance it is our ability to do.
What can your and should you do for Africa. We do our does a lot of things for Africa.
So we are in line with what I have just say.
We believe capacity is very critical capacity at the end of the day capacity is development development is all about
capacity of people. So we have a very large capacity building unit.
So every year we see one hundred to one hundred fifty graduate students all across Africa they do they do they do mass
that we have a master's degree they are a Ph D.
Degree so and then we train them they are registering in many different universities
but they do the research at this a bit.
And so we are in Hans seeing the scientific capability of many African countries own insect science
but also we train also a lot of farmers in different things. We we train in the technology certainly adopt from us.
And so on. So like this year from John already until October.
Tandems this is a ten month as we we three and one of them ten thousand people in various different acknowledged.
So this is big. And we have a lot of the small organization. So I think this is a big contribution. So we we also.
Our products go look up. Technologists to go.
So one of the things which is difficult for us is to scale lots of technologies to reach as many people as we can. So.
What example we have the technologists you are going to visit tomorrow in the field is a absolutely fabulous technology.
Invented created by and developed by its partners.
But this is a technology that is really needed all across Africa but be bad.
We are reaching only ten to twenty thousand people far more spread a year
but the technology is needed by millions of foreigners.
So now we are changing our model and partner noting with governments and with any just
and was a private sector to take the technology into accelerated in many different countries. Yeah.
You're not a different discussion. To many people share your sort.
Wherever you can share because you also go to the president of your country or yeah so.
So yeah this is a very important we are not it's very important for us to because the governments and to fit also with.
Strategy plan also so we kind of just want Korean isolation.
So that utopian government has for example has a very clear strategy development plan.
So they took a number of our products and technologists and they fit them into their into their strategy.
For one of our technologies for example they have a plan to reach minimum of twenty thousand farmers with that
technology a year. So they are going to expand it themselves.
I think once a gives up and we do the technical backstopping. Because it's a very knowledge intensive technology.
So you have to train farmers. How to to to use it but it's a fabulous technology and a beekeeping so that.
They utilize beekeeping anything insects that we work on silk farming also is very needed so it's not just only food
security but also income generation you want to improve the livelihood of people in various ways.
It's not just only producing more food and that's it. But you want also to diversify their income.
That reduces the risk mitigation so if you have a diverse income. You are you are not dependent on one.
So you're already seeing this discount so yeah. So what would be your ultimate scientific goal.
OK that's a big question I think. A more doable one. So I think so. Tomorrow you would see this field visits.
In the field one of the critical critical problems across Africa in many countries is a parasitic weed called Strike it
is a parasite on many cereal crops on rice on maize on sort of Gram one million the staples that people need staple
food. And basically this is a part of it at that seed self.
To the roots of its host is a maze of sort of them or whatever it takes all the nutrients out.
It cannot live without without that host. And visit. So if you have that.
It also produces a lot of seeds like thousands of seeds tiny seeds and it sheds into the soil
and so once you have started this is really the soil is busy. Unusable.
So we have a technologist at the cutting eradicate that.
So what I really would like to see in my lifetime is eradicating the say weed from all across Africa
and it's possible we have the technology what is needed is to scale it out.
To get the large law and number of partners and
and funders to say OK we are out to eradicate descend then we have to go into a major problem food security probably
put Africa. I would like to see that was in my lifetime. And I think it's doable.
How important are the insects for more sustainable.
And that are very important in many young girls there are important. If you manage them well that important in.
Cleaning our environment that important in and being the watercourse of farms that important as food source.
I mean all these. Chicken that are sold as the organic chicken that are free roaming in the. In the Fathom.
Why do they dig and dig and they pick since it's so you might you can mass produce that and produce a bigger chicken.
And more so in a more sustainable way. Fishery aqua culture.
That's more so as well so insects can play a critical role in. In a more sustainable production system.
So I can go on and when I think really important. Yeah that's important in.
But also enjoy because you want a more sustainable Africa. Yes.
So I think they they have even more so here because we have me rather for diversity of insects as diversity of ecology
say our ecology cult zones are be that of varieties that are a lot of different plants. All year round.
So a lot of these insects also they rely on own. Planned sugar source. As their thing.
So I see many people don't know what skittles they don't just go and take my blend
and they live on that they need to specific or so to sustain them specific plant can take that as a source of.
Sugar is this is so I detect more so for Africa because of our diversity of ecology diversity of plants diversity of of
things. We just we keep discovering new things this year alone.
We discovered and published out attack on attacks on our mists and partners.
Fifteen different new wasps which have never been described in anywhere in the winter
and there are some of them that are also beneficial because they feed on harmful insects. We have discovered. So in.
Where we are going tomorrow. One of our scientists is to discover that there is a jumping spider jumping spider.
That is attracted only to. That that are filled with blood with human blood. So they jump and if you don't do side.
Insects. If you give them. As that insects. They they wouldn't say go specifically full stop was good.
But they are a lot smaller scale. With that specific jumping spider also requires subtlety and plant. Sugar source.
To sustain it also between its means. Skittle blood filled mosquitoes. We call it via vampire spiders.
As so what it means is also that if you keep. So Stipe of plants in your habitat. You are going to manage also.
To keep the brain more so that the art of maintaining the spiders that feed on your the mosquitoes.
That will be less mosquitoes to transmit. Out all it is not in black and white. It's not in in boxes. It's a continuum.
So we have to manage it doesn't continue to make it very stressed and never. Very natural.
For the future
and so if you cause imbalance too by eliminating certain type of insects from more certain type of plants.
Then they just. You are causing also an imbalance in your environment.
What would be the way to go from Africa disrespect I mean you have say to European agricultural system
or like to us is that the way to go for what you. Yeah. That was an excellent question.
But also a complicated question. And I so you can debate it is a way.
OK you can debate it is the way because while and so for example seventy percent of.
Generally sixty to seventy percent of the population in in Africa is engaged in agriculture.
I don't think that is a smart way to keep that a large proportion of the. Your population in far me.
So if you go Europe or North America and Canada you have about four or five percent of the population.
So it is very inefficient to to have seventy percent of your population to read at least.
So this is not efficient way to do it. So we have to do it better.
So also but I think technology scientific technology alone is not going to do the trick.
So we have to have the right policy. We have to have a right environment to do these things.
Why do I say policy policy is is important in this because it has to be the right policy to land.
And access to land access to resources. So if you take.
For example many African countries without the mentioning a specific country. You have land.
The farmers has to begin is very small land.
So they have a farmer may have six seven children father mother dies the six seven children split their land.
So these are one of them can make a living out of such pieces. Small pieces of land.
So we have to have a policy to to stop fragmenting the the land.
To pieces because it cannot make a living out of it you can transform agriculture was small pieces.
You cannot do a lot of different things so so so so that has to be a policy also that is favorable to two to enabling a
transformation of agriculture through should.
Be a big to produce more was was less so and we have to make out I'd like our share is more efficient
and utilization i also a lot of proportion of the out of farming system is when Fed that's not so son of a new way.
To wait for the rain waiting in the sky for a drop of water to drop sads and it's a smart way to do
and only four percent of our land is all of the farmland is it a gated
and yet we have a lot of water flowing in it will have a lot of also water. Being waste with the dough so this whole.
There's a lot of different things that we have to do to. To to transform our farming system.
So having said that this is not. I don't believe that one more deal. Alone is the model for Africa.
So it may not be the European model but there are a lot of things we can go from. I dropped from the European.
Land access to the sort of efficiency in part of me and so on.
So it's it's not the it's not the black and white times that I can give you.
But
but what I know is that we cannot continue keeping a large population of the population percentage of out of provisioning
for me that's just not doable system if you imagine a future where the knowledge about insects will be short of export
product for. A. Yes actually. Yes there are you can repeat my question.
Yeah and OK well what kind of future and do injections have for and so can we use insects as Africa use insects
or exports but a duck. Yes absolutely. I believe so. This is not actually even.
Something for the long run but it's already short track.
There are companies that are already exploring to establish a plant here in Africa to produce mass grave insects.
For a feed. To Europe and somewhere else. So yeah this is going to happen in the near future.
Actually you know maybe you can sort of give it a compressed answer on how important interactions are in terms of
danger. You know like what you said to many there are many deaths caused by injection.
Many more by malaria and the other kind of
but also beneficial things so little bit of sort of breast cancer that appeared to do what they said yeah OK.
So if you would have to tell a nice story about one insects are meaningful to me and for us.
What will be your story line. Yeah be very very important for them for. For humankind.
So we have to protect beasts resulted.
So we have to make sure that they are healthy and they leave nice nicely happily and. There are many ways to do that.
Phil and.
They need to have good pollen plant source
and so on so beside number one I think they're bad among the top which we need to do not predict have sprayed it at
insects sad really important does what we did that to feed on harmful insects that hadn't put people to our animals.
It's not important as well so. But tatting we have to or so. Pay attention and try. So you.
That advocate they'll find a solution also so you owe me rather for major diseases that are transmitted by by insects
keep those. Like it is that transmitted to malaria. That transmits dengue.
That Transmeta also a number of causes the disease was in i months and humans. Rift Valley fever.
Yellow fever and the number of other diseases etc for Africa says if life says he flies. Really quickly got money many.
For to land. Thailand in Africa has become you know abandoned by people because of this is if life infestation.
So this adult to very important.
All these things I have described saddled so focused will be sipping my organisation to do so as this are some of the
important thing. So I would say yeah we were called to school so. Take six and take one disease.
This are not just after a couple of nepotism because America has a little demand we have products in the pipeline.
That that really fictive natural products from from plants. As other microbes was in Africa.
So I think the beauty of it is.
Is Africa has a lot of this problem insect program
but the whole lot of also sort of sort of for controlling this so for all of these problems that I have indicated.
Like this is it flies we have a product for example which came from the wildlife wild animals in Aden in Africa.
So much. I have a feeling that you're introducing has a lot of hidden treasures I don't. Yes we do it yeah absolutely.
Yes it's going to can you repeat it. Yeah.
And disappear I think has a lot of important unique three ships that that's not widely known.
But I think also we had a making tremendous effort to you for the rest of the world to to know what we are capable of
being and what we have. So and I think also I have to also indicate that. The Superior does it is.
Also work with a lot of partners and nobody. So we have.
More than three hundred partners in Europe North America Latin America swim and we're.
Including then eleven months we have a lot of parts to say and so so yeah. So how do you get these treasures.
Into the world. Yet lots is a critical large think it's critical to scale out what we have so that.
The rest of the planet can and Africa can make use of what we have. At a faster rate and that is a challenge.
That's a big challenge because it is sort of the musician.
Is it is said to the musician and it's very difficult for the search organization to scale out.
And to reach out to the Globe on a global forum on a global platform and so partners become very important
and funding becomes important source of funding. Our funding.
We are not a government organization we are we have international organizations that happen to be based in Kenya.
So the funding comes from a lot of the sources that you. So the European Union is among the investors the donors.
The governments of. Of Germany Sweden Souza London and U.K.
Money foundations the provide funding for us to make that excellent make a change.
So I think all these resources I think have to be made available not just what Africa
but for I think there are some landed as well because this is also we are using the funds of the taxpayer Sophie to
open to North America and so on so too.
We didn't have it this way since these products and find solution for the constraints.
Are totally out of question if you would have to describe your philosophy of life we would be. Going to you.
And you met your future. Yeah. She loves the feel of life. I think for me.
My motto personality is
and I tell my daughter also I have one daughter who is going to be a scientist so she just joined the university in
America. First you.
So I My motto is leave life was a purpose not just for yourself
or to really it's to to contribute to changing lives for those people who are less fortunate than we are
and I think there are millions of people who don't have the skills of the resources that we have.
So it would be a tragedy for any human kind to leave for himself or herself like if I have a good life myself.
Yes that is this like OK. So I think we have to you if we see the suffering of a fellow human being.
We have to suffer together we have to feel the pain. And so. And I think if we have the means and invests the skills.
We should do it. We should make use of it. So that.
Again you see that showing is changing because our knowledge is spreading quicker than ever. Around the planet. Yeah.
Yeah. Who is a science is making a difference a planet that appears to me. We want.
That this question of oh I don't have.
Yes sort of nonsense however I know that our lives have tremendously changed because of controversial science if you
just. Back several decades back before the the invention of Fundy about ics.
Before we had access to the first Sunday about it. Penicillin. We just accidentally disc.
A hundred from
and more from a fungus that before that people were dying for a very simple truth ability is from infection.
Infections.
So that's not the kids anymore and so and then since the discovery of penicillin a lot of range of antibiotics
and is discovered from microbes from plants from other sources. So yes.
Science has made tremendous difference for for us. The vaccines.
Polio is almost eradicate And so here and there are only vaccines. People are dying from a lot of prevent.
Preventive does but that the tragedy if it is even to this day.
Preventable diseases are still killing people in the developing world to do things a lot of dying from infection
because they don't have access to simple on the about ticks or they don't say
or didn't have them in sort of the knowledge that there actually is if they vaccinate the kids at certain ages they
would have prevented so some.
Diseases I at this day myself I don't know what I have been vaccinated I don't think I've been vaccinated
when I was I was a kid.
This is this is the world believes the haves and the have nots and that got so big a difference.
But but yes science has made a tremendous tremendous difference in our lives.
And I think to continue doing it but I think governments have to value.
Science not only in Africa but globally and do significant investment also in science and technology where.